[Music]
[Music]
homie look what I become
[Music]
like that [ __ ] you know okay we are
back episode number 205 home team Adam's
back from Dallas I'm back from DC Tom is
back from Boynton Beach and Vinnie is
back from uh Iraq from Iraq yes anyways
how was your trip do you see yeah it was
good A lot of people wearing masks I
don't know why are you serious regular
people outside Warren masks stop it I'm
telling you and these years
secret I'm with tikram people wore masks
in DC it's very surprised let me tell
you something I was in Dallas buddy
nobody that's right it's a different
story
so a lot A lot's happened that we got to
talk we got a lot of things to talk
about Trump gave a speech okay so we got
some commentary on that I know then you
watched the whole thing Tom you got some
opinions Adam you got some entitles got
some as well there's mixed reviews about
his speech there's a lot going on there
there's Ivanka you know the next day
making her announcement who was there
who wasn't there was Kushner there was
the sun there Matt Gates last minute you
know bailed out I can the weather's bad
there's just a lot of the New York Post
went after Trump trying to troll him you
know DeSantis was asked about it he gave
his commentary telling everybody to
Shell out a little bit and just relax
instead of asking me these questions but
we got some to cover over there FBI
director very interesting it was CIA
first announced FBI director
talking about Tick Tock they're
concerned that could benefit Twitter
long term by the way Elon Musk says in
court he doesn't want to be CEO of any
company and we have a bunch of stats
that Tom's got to share with us here U.S
household debt in Q3 sword
351 billion dollars I think we got 16 16
and a half trillion dollars
in uh debt credit card debt I believe a
lot of Americans are no longer tipping
20 and inflation may be the one to blame
that's a market watch story get ready
for the most expensive Thanksgiving ever
most homeowners using helocs as
Financial safety net UK inflation hits a
41 year high 11.1 percent billions of
dollars seem to have disappeared from
this collapse of FTX and by the way the
guy is still not stopping to troll
people he keeps trolling over and over
on Twitter and he's being arrogant about
it very interesting character this this
guy said yeah yeah very very interesting
guy more than a million creditors could
be affected by an FTX bailout uh fallout
Poland says Missile Crisis missile
strike near uh Ukraine border was likely
an accident caused by misfiring you
create a Ukrainian air defense even
though zielinski came out immediately
blaming Russia whiteout asked Congress
for 37 billion dollars more Ukraine ad
in horrific move Iran's Parliament votes
to execute this is this is a you would
think this is not a true story but it's
a story by Reuters and many
in a horrific move Iran's Parliament
votes to execute 15 000 protesters to
teach hard lessons we'll get into that
McConnell win Senate leadership uh
Michelle Obama may be running this is a
CNS uh story
humiliates Trudeau and there's an
Adderall shortage puts U.S on brink of
Public Health crisis we may cover that
as well anyways it's good to be with you
guys we're happy to see you I'm happy to
see you I saw a video on Instagram where
it's like somebody's POV of Pat walking
in down this hallway I thought Jesus
Christ came back so I just said wow wow
what was it was it was a great event man
shout out to Chris embasseen heart they
had a big office right now and it was
Calverton we had a good time it was
awesome it was ridiculous amazing yeah
very very good energy okay so let's get
into it do we want to go with Trump
first is that what we want to do first
let's get it out
I say we do economy first I want to go
into economy first and then we'll go
into Trump so just go to page six uh Tom
I'm gonna read first one here U.S
household debt and Q3 soared by 351
billion dollars at fastest Pace in 15
years
during the third quarter at the fastest
Pace in 15 years due to Hefty increases
in credit card usage and mortgage
balances the Federal Reserve reported
Tuesday the total debt jumped 351
billion dollars from July to September
the largest nominal quarterly increase
since 2007 bringing the collective
household ious in the U.S to Fresh 16
and a half trillion dollars that's an
increase of 2.2 percent from the
previous quarter 8.3 percent from a year
ago the increase follows a 310 billion
dollar jump in a second quarter and
represents 1.27 trillion dollar annual
increase Tom what's going on over there
well this is a sign of what is happening
with inflation to the average American
and they're turning to their credit
cards let me connect some Dots here
there's there's a couple quick points
for y'all first of all we see a headline
on this boy look at this jumping debt
well what's going on then you turn to
Walmart and Target earnings I dove into
both of them Walmart very telling they
said apparel dropped Home Improvement
and Home Goods dropped that's called
discretionary and Goldman Sachs came out
and said we're seeing discretionary
spending drop we don't think interest
rates are going to Peak until May where
the FED they believe is going to make it
five and a quarter so they're looking at
a half a point in December quarter
points start the year capping at five
and a quarter in May why is that
important well where's all this debt
it's on credit cards so I went and
looked up the Visa and MasterCard
earnings from three weeks ago guess what
they're both up in the middle of all
this and they said consumer spending was
strong but even Visa said it's what
they're spending on they're spending on
groceries and when you dive into the
Walmart story was very interesting they
said that there is a shift in proteins
because remember Walmart and Target
compete but Walmart is like 45 Grocery
and Target is not Target's got sodas and
chips and some groceries but nothing
compared to Walmart so you would expect
Target to be harder hit if discretionary
so I looked that up guess what they were
so Walmart is seeing people move to
groceries they have analysts and a lot
of their customers and they even said
that by their analytics hundred thousand
dollar customers were moving to Walmart
branded groceries for Staples like flour
you know that the generic Walmart brand
on flower baby formula diapers they said
the Walmart house Brands were doing
better than the more premium prices
typically 10 to 20 cheaper is that a
fair number to say totally fair number
yeah absolutely so what we're seeing
this spending is saying that consumers
are putting a lot of inflation on the
credit card number one it should one
man's interest is another man's ebitda
think about that Pat the interest on a
credit card becomes ebitda for a Visa
that's a good point and it showed up in
their earnings report you know yesterday
while I'm in DC I'm talking to a bunch
of these folks and I said so let me ask
you a question what's the biggest thing
you're concerned about the room is about
70 percent uh women you hear ladies
saying grocery shopping has gone up I
said I said what do you mean by it yep a
milk today 529 to buy milk and it was
three dollars last year I said what do
you mean milk has gone up from whatever
was three bucks to 529 the first thing
they talked about was milk I mean you
have to these are mothers these are
parents these are sitting there saying
what they're got to be doing with it and
by the way when people start spending a
little bit more on credit card what is
it saying to you it's saying uh they
kind of need it its emergency a lot of
people use their credit cards as a
source of emergency fund although
emergency funds should be an emergency
fund not a credit card so people are
leaning towards credit cards so it's
going to be interesting what happens
next quarter because whether it's
trending
towards uh this happening more uh but
it's never good when you're seeing
consumers leaning towards credit cards
now Adam what do you got to say about
this uh speaking of milk you saw our
friend Marcelo Hernandez on uh SNL this
weekend uh on uh Weekend Update he's
like milk what are you a baby who drinks
milk yeah it was so funny
um so shout out to him but it's
interesting because obviously Tom is
very very uh uh insightful when it comes
to the macroeconomics I always kind of
my expertise is more on the personal
finance what I love about saying
personal finance it's your money
personal finance so it's interesting
because in 2020 and 2021 Tom you
probably know the exact stats but we saw
that more people were getting out of
debt more people were saving more people
were reversing the trend of how much
they're putting on credit cards and you
know stacking cash in the bank and just
like that you know after all the
stimulus all the unemployment back to
normal like 2022 let's ball out let's go
on vacation let's buy some milk let's
get crazy here so you know at the end of
the day it comes down to personal
finance and individual responsibility
when you got your tax refund and you got
your stimulus and you got your you know
you made a little extra you got your
bonus what did you do with it did you go
on vacation did you save it did you
actually pay down debt or did you kind
of just repeat the same vicious cycle of
paycheck to paycheck you know debt debt
accumulation you know what's interesting
is you talking about credit cards you
know there's this HELOC story and like
the average credit card is what 18 19
and then people are basically if you own
a home obviously there's been great
appreciation in your home equity and
your home values people are tapping into
their HELOC their home equity line of
credit and that tends to be around what
seven eight percent ish correct seven
seven five average today there it is
that's what we got Tom those exact
numbers I love it
um so that's still not a great number I
mean even these days I'm so disappointed
in you I've got to tell you because
we're setting you up to say this segment
is produced by Silk soy milk and you
don't know
but if you don't want to be a soy boy
you want to be a silly man drink but you
bring up the HELOC yeah let's connect
the dot on that very interesting right
now so they're 775. I took a look at the
pop and HELOC and I said well what makes
helocs go up well helocs go up can you
can you Tom the average person may not
know what a HELOC is home equity line of
credit you know if if a person doesn't
know what a HELOC is why are people
getting helocs right now because there
is a stat that's telling us about what's
going on with helocs where more
homeowners are using HELOC today this is
a Wall Street Journal story let me just
read that and then I'll set you up and
you go into it perfect so Wall Street
Journal homeowners using helocs as
Financial safety net American took 66
billion dollars in home equity line of
credits or helocs in the second quarter
a 40 increase from a year ago in the
largest amount in almost three years
these accounts which allow homeowners to
borrow against the value of their homes
are making a comeback as higher rates
make it less favorable to refinance your
loan a HELOC works like a credit card
but since it's backed by your property
generally offers a much more favorable
interest rate the average HELOC rate is
7.7 comparable with the average 19.04
APR on credit cards and 10.6 for average
personal loan rate owners get a credit
card line based on a home equity line
but don't have to use all or even any of
the available funds go ahead Tom so it's
really interesting so HELOC home equity
line of credit basically a credit card
based on your house because your credit
card in your wallet is based on your
salary and that's very simple way to
look at it and what what has happened is
I dug into so if helocs are being
opened and the dollars are going up what
two companies might you go look for in
their earnings report to see spend visa
and Chase I don't know uh Home Depot and
Lowe's oh though there you go so I dove
into Hope Depot and Lowe's and guess
what they both had a big pop in the
second quarter so people are using the
HELOC to make Improvement on their house
the danger of HELOC is that the HELOC
like if your credit card balances go up
you'll probably notice that all of a
sudden you get a letter that says hey
your thirty thousand dollar limit is now
down to 27.5 the banks are actually
aggressive and proactive about raising
and lowering your credit limit well so
too that the helocs work the helocs look
at the value of houses and if the bank
detects there is a risk they'll pull it
back a little bit so right now and some
of those helocs have floating rates so
if interest rates are going up and
helocs are already seven three quarters
now and housing prices are going to go
down you're probably going to see a
little squeeze on HELOC but it also
means that people are investing in their
house because they're having issues
selling them so I'm like okay are houses
selling or not selling let me see some
stats this week this stuff's moving
every week so I went and I found check
this out Redfin I think we covered this
a couple weeks ago remember they had
this house flipping business hey sell us
your house we'll flip it we'll give you
all this money and then you can go
figure out where you're gonna buy any
more expensive house or rent good luck
well there is an example that was in
there that was in Nevada seven-year-old
neighborhood outside Las Vegas so this
is part of the Vegas expansion this is
an old home seven-year-old house
Redfin bought it
in May for six hundred and ten thousand
dollars two bedrooms two baths they put
it on the market June 1st at six hundred
and seventy four thousand dollars
redfins thinking they're gonna flip it's
been sitting
for 140 days and it's been reduced to
4.99 and it's still sitting so I looked
at that and I'm like okay is this an
outlier let me recap this they bought it
for 610 they put it for 674. it's been
sitting for 140 days they put it out
4.99 and it's still sitting and it's in
a seven-year-old neighborhood outside
Vegas if you've been to Vegas you fly in
you see all those neighborhoods where
the working people in Vegas live this
isn't a middle of nowhere house this is
a suburban area that's relatively new
and that is a sign of what's happening
so back to HELOC people are trying to
improve their houses or doing some work
it's benefiting the stocks so now
last Point let's go back to a week ago
you said how is the economy so bad but
the market is up well there's how Home
Depot and Lowe's and Walmart are up
because of credit cards and HELOC so how
long can the market live on the
consumers using other people's money
they're turning into debt we need one of
those sounds where you press the button
what is it called those books oh
soundboard soundboard where it says wow
yeah that right there I mean I've only
been asking that for a few years Adam
you're talking about the personal
finance part the people and I get it
like people that are in the cities and
around people like you guys that you
know we could talk to but what about
what do you say to the average Joe
person that like you said like when uh
stimulus check and all the Investments
but about the average guy in Montana
that has a regular family that's getting
their money and whatever and then all
this stuff is happening and then like
some of the Democrats like Joy reads
like inflation you guys are just coming
up with that you that's you guys are
watching news what do you tell those
people that are just living it day to
day and then now they're feeling it and
it's coming you know what I'm saying
there's um you're asking a personal
finance and how to handle your money
what's the question no not me personally
I mean they're not some of the people
out there they're not investing on the
market they're just living their average
life they're putting their social
security and everything but now
everything is going up everything
nothing's changing for them Tom made a
very very good point right now I think
it's very important to emphasize what
Tom just said so you know uh oh I
remember when I was in trouble
financially I'm 22 years old 23 years
old my credit card I had twenty thousand
dollars left in my credit cards and I I
don't have a job I don't have a way to
pay my bills I was paying my bills every
month with credit cards and it looked
like everything was good but I only had
four or five more months like that when
the fifth month came everything was done
my car got repoed but I was driving
parking it all over the place this is 2
000 okay I'm parking my car in Granada
Hills a mile away behind the park to
walk to my house so you know so you
don't get repo
eventually 90 days later I turned my car
in I'm paying my phone bill in the
following way I'm calling Nextel no joke
and I'm asking Nextel what will 73
dollars get me how many days I owed 1500
to Nextel I haven't paid my phone bill
they would say 73 dollars will turn your
phone on for six days can you do it for
10 days they would say yes I would
negotiate paying phone payment by days
and I would pay 73 dollars because I'm a
salesperson I need my phone every time
people would call my phone and it would
give that one weird message you know
what that message is when you haven't
paid your bills
a subscribe and you have to say have you
guys noticed Nextel having issues lately
oh yeah yeah I've tried to call you yeah
it's next time I'm thinking about
switching to you know somebody else
anyways at that time and then all of a
sudden the day came where it's like look
you don't have 73 dollars you don't have
a car are you don't have money you don't
have credit what the hell are you now
gonna do what Tom just predicted is a
lot of people are about to hit that
possibly in six to nine months did you
see the savings uh um
earlier this year total savings we had
as Americans was 2. trillion dollars we
were collectively trillionaires I don't
know if you knew this every American
yeah you could say we the people we the
people okay we were trillionaires q1 of
uh 2022 this year it went from 2.3
trillion each quarter we've lost 300
billion dollars so we went from 2.3
trillion to 2 trillion to 1.7 trillion
we're at 1.6 trillion right now as we're
still trillionaires yes as savings
depletes yeah you make decisions in a
different way ask the question in DC I
said you know 2.3 trillion to 1.6
trillion doesn't seem like a lot of
money and some people are like well it's
a lot of money we lost I said let's
change it let's just say your cash in
the bank went from twenty three thousand
dollars to sixteen thousand dollars are
you and your husband or wife having a
conversation right now you would be
amazed how many how many women in the
audience said absolutely to go from 23
to 16 000 that's a scary number so if
you went from from 23 to 16 000 in six
months you're concerned Americans
collectively went from two point two
three trillion to 1.6 trillion so if Tom
is right and we're going in that
direction today Lowe's Home Depot
Walmart these guys are the beneficiaries
of people spending money on credit cards
especially but but stuff could be very
nasty six months from now did you see
what happened with Target uh Target I
think yesterday announced that because
of organized retail crime they lost 400
million dollars this year for think
about that 400 hold that up 400 million
dollars because they're saying organized
crime but like Pat and Cali they lowered
that thing where you could steal under a
thousand bucks and just the cops won't
even come after you you know yeah San
Francisco 500.
organized retail crime
400 million dollars Vinnie are you
thinking about it I'm thinking like a
side uh I mean think about it in
California you could if you think about
it uh Pat Tom you could go into every
Walmart every CVS steal under a thousand
dollars they're not even chasing you
people are just recording it and they
put it on you know world star and
YouTube and you could just get dude if
you hit four of those a day go to
another city that's you and just sell it
on on Amazon you want to go into
business with me or like what are we
talking about right now I mean as much
as we're having fun with this story this
is not funny it's not funny if your
target yeah and this is just Target
blames organized retail crime for 400
million dollars loss in profits this
year that's insane to be thinking about
right that this is now a business model
for some that's what yeah I would love
to know breakdowns for a state like what
state California I'm sure
I'm saying Target loses one million one
hundred and fifty thousand dollars a day
on theft yeah
number that's insane can you zoom in a
little bit I'm trying to find September
okay let me just read that one right
there in September the CEO of Rite Aid
said Tyler can you zoom in please a
little bit yeah there you go uh so the
pharmacy chain was burdened with a five
million year over year increase in a
shrink a terminal retail industry which
means losses related to theft fraud or
administrative errors right at CEO uh
Donna again told analysts that the
problem was particularly acute in New
York City there you go I think the
headline here is the environment that we
operate in particularly in New York City
is not conductive conducive to reducing
shrink just based upon everything you
read and see on social media and the
news and the city who's uh who's the big
uh singer is it Selena Selena Gomez her
brother got robbed and shot or something
in New York City did you see that it was
recent somebody did just get shot I
don't know if it was Selena was somebody
else who's the other girl it's um
who's who's uh uh Ariana Grande I'm
sorry Ariana Grande's brother type in
Ariana's there you go and then go to
news
Ariana Grande's brother Frankie Grande
39 viciously mugged in New York City by
13 years 13 year old kid can you imagine
that what go down to see if he was shot
or was just mug zoom in a little bit
Ariana Grande's brother Frankie Grande
was viciously mugged by a 13 year old
punk in another scene in Midtown
Manhattan Frankie social media
personality and a 39 Year brother
popular pop star it's a Avenue between
43rd and 44th Street around 6 p.m it's
not even Dark Yet on November 9 when he
was attacked in front of Saturn dolls
gentlemen's club and sports bar cops his
muggers a 13 year old boy and a 17 year
old smashed Frankie in the back of the
head cop said and uh he's hanging out
he's hanging out one of those late night
uh gentlemen clubs those libraries
networking events I'll bring up a couple
points um have you seen that Meme
speaking of Housing and Redfin and all
that yeah there's like a meme going
around with like a real estate agent is
taking a couple to purchase a house or
look at a house and the couple goes uh
could you show us something a little
more inexpensive they go sure we'll just
come back to the same house tomorrow so
we'll just start right back here
so and then a couple more points you
know I heard a crazy stat crazy stat
they said if I brought this up before
when we were when they were doing all
the stimulus and two trillion dollar
stimulus in the cares Act and the
buildback Becker trillion trillion
trillion trillion do you know
if you and our good friend Jesus Christ
went into business
2022 plus years ago and you made a
million dollars every single day million
million million million year in year out
year after year 2 000 plus years that
would not even equal one trillion
dollars just to put it in perspective at
this point if you do the math it's like
750 billion dollars just to give you
some context to how much a trillion is
and last thing oh sorry it's good to
hear your friends with this guy yeah
this is who I pray to as a Jew the money
the Jesus the trillion this is my
favorite thing is Adam's book of the
case for Jesus Christ shout out to
Ruslan gave it to me haven't opened it
yet but when I do and it's going to get
right that
um the blood of Christ but the back to
your point I I try to simplify things to
for you know the average American out
there uh I don't drive a car but if I
did I would probably stop at red lights
okay yeah my Uber driver does from time
to time but with anything
um especially personal finance there's
red there's yellow there's green okay
and what category are most Americans in
most Americans are in the red light Camp
meaning they're paycheck to paycheck
they're drowning in debt they they're
not they don't they have no emergency
fund they don't have money in the bank
they're red the goal is to get from red
to Yellow to green yellow is maybe when
you're out of debt and you have some
savings right you haven't become an
investor yet you're not a homeowner 50
of Americans have no Investments
whatsoever I think one-third of
Americans are still only renting right
talking about tapping into helocs but
the goal is to get to that green light
phase where the money's good you're
investing you're not worried about
paycheck to paycheck like for instance
when you're telling this story about
when you're 22 right I mean when's the
last time you worried about making rent
this month right when's the last time
you even had that feeling most Americans
got to pay rent this month like I went
from that red light to yellow light to
Green Light someone asked me the other
day it's like when's the last time you
had to worry about rent I'm like
probably like I don't know over five
seven years I don't know 10 years ago
about rent yeah so most Americans are
worried about rent and when you can go
from day to day week to week month to
month and you can kind of think what am
I doing next year or three years or your
next five moves five years from now it's
a very comforting field
uh real quick a question for Pat and Tom
we're kind of looking at the micro level
individual to individual yeah so bank
rate says as of September 22 average
debt among consumers is 96 000 what
happens when you tie this into the net
does that include the car yeah that
includes car house all over everything
across the board 96. so 100 Grand
basically yeah the average American owes
I'd like to know what it is without the
Mortgage Debt Clock has debt per
taxpayer 250 000 so you're now looking
at 350 000 essentially in debt in total
right how does this tie into national
debt how do we dig ourselves out of this
hole does how does this like are they
non-sequiturs does it not like can you
not compare them what does it do to the
dollar like how do we dig ourselves
about this I have very strong feelings
Tom you can go there there are two rules
of two schools of thought on there and
the first is
we're set for a massive economic reset
someday because you just can't stop this
and the other side is no you don't have
to worry about it deficit spending you
just print I mean take a look at what
um what we just did as a nation and
printing 40 of the total currency and
searches the modern monetary Theory
that's right modern monetary Theory says
it really doesn't matter
um you just you're just going to print
and you're going to grow and you know
nothing is nothing is ever going to be
more debt and value than than the land
and resources of your country which is
it's kind of dangerous so I I think
we're seeing
a gridlock Washington with the two
schools are unable to control the other
one is we're just going to print and we
get deficits look we have to go back to
Clinton to find a president that came
closest to having a balanced budget and
when everybody hears when you hear about
balance budget amendment what that means
is the government spends on defense and
ships and bombs and national parks and
all the stuff that we do and jails and
prisons and all that what they spent was
exactly what came in from income taxes
corporate taxes and tariffs and other
supplemental taxes that we have the
taxes that came in they spent
it's been since the Clinton
Administration where we were even
freaking close to a balanced budget so
we are spending can I get my opinion on
this so and then Tom he's asking for
Solutions so can we do anything about
this that's that's what zero okay your
point is I don't think in a gridlock
sorry in a gridlock Washington I don't
think you're ever going to be able to
control so how can I get a balanced
budget go ahead what do you think can be
done about this
I mean I I will tell you my issue but I
want to hear yours first I'm going to
give I'll be the heel in this situation
because I know you're going to come up
with a solution so I know that you're
going to have something but I say this
all the time there's things that matter
and there's things that you can control
where you should focus are were those
two things intersect does our national
debt matter of course like if you look
at this chart for longer than two
seconds your head's gonna explode with
all the numbers and up and down
but at the end it's a very selfish
answer you cannot worry about this you
can only worry about what you can do
with your own household now granted are
there different policies that you can
vote for are there different politicians
that you can vote for but when's the
last time Clinton was in office 2000 so
last 22 years nobody's done [ __ ] about
this debt but that's also at a time
where they used to work together they
don't work together today back then they
used to you know go and say hey need
your help man let's figure this out I'll
give you this you give me this if have
you guys ever read the book
um
the guy who was his right-hand Guy
what's his name oh um
no no no he was like the chief of staff
he was an absolute Beastie guy or James
Brady James yeah so Jim Baker's book
it's like 1500 pages man it's it's a
long book but if you ever read it you
will see how many times Reagan went
across the aisle and said hey can we
let's figure out a way to negotiate and
see what we can do about this here's my
opinions on this Tyler okay the issue
with this getting fixed is our current
election system and and what I mean by
the election system is the following
thing or whatever way you elect your uh
uh your candidates or your politicians
everybody today benefits from giving
things away for free
and because the system is in a way where
you have to get reelected every four
years the right person and the right
policies to fix this would never get
elected today so so in order for this to
get fixed you need you need 20 years of
President House and Senate to all be
bought into paying off the national debt
to even address this issue it's not
going to happen because those policies
will never get somebody to say oh so
what we need to do is stop spending what
we need to do is keep a reasonable
interest rate up and what we need to do
is stop trying to chase all these other
things for how long 20 years I'm all in
let's go do it and pay off our debt
people aren't going to buy into that not
to mention who are the people that were
electing into Congress now the future
generation is a generation built on the
idea that that you have to go into
massive amounts of debt to make any
money right the college student like
look at AOC how much debt was seen
before we elected her to Congress this
this is what she's built her foundation
on is debt right so we have to have a
Groundswell a a cultural change wherein
people not just the government people as
themselves we have to stop this idea you
know how dramatic that dramatic of a
philosophy that is look you know who
benefits long term think about it this
way Elon Musk gets 180 million dollars
FDC sells PayPal we just talked about a
couple weeks ago he sells PayPal gets
180 million he chooses to put 100
million dollars into SpaceX he chooses
to put 70 million dollars into Tesla he
chooses to put 10 million dollars into
the solar business that he has fast
forward later today's Worth to 200
billion dollars one day he's worth 300
billion one day he's worth 150 billion
give or take he's worth 150 to 300
billion dollars but he can say I'll buy
Twitter for 44 billion and he can go out
there and say I'm buying the company I'm
going to figure out a way to buy it
right why did he do that he's a
long-term thinker he's a long-term
thinker we have become such short-term
thinkers that we just want to elect
somebody that can solve our problems now
I want to drink a you know drink that's
gonna make me lose 10 pounds for
tomorrow's party now I want to take
something in my body that my muscles are
going to be 18 guns now I want to buy a
Bitcoin that's going to help me become a
millionaire now everything is this now
mentality and unfortunately we vote with
now mentality we buy with now mentality
we sell with now mentality we build with
now mentality no one's thinking about
delayed gratification we do something in
our house and some people say is that
the right thing to do as a parent
so you if you come into my office right
now Dylan's got 40 gifts sitting in my
office he's got 40 gifts in my office
okay packed up wrapped up these are
people that brought gifts over dinner's
birthday was September 24th today is
what November 17th November what's
today's date yes November 17th okay so
Dylan gets to open 10 gifts that he gets
on his birthday
so people get 100 gifts that comes over
pick your 10 gifts he opens 10 gifts
that night then the rest of the gifts go
my office and if he's good every week he
gets to open up three to five gifts
every week you know how long those gifts
last those gifts last six months so
guess what happens every week he has to
earn the right to open up a gift that
produces long-term thinking we're not
teaching long-term thinking all we're
teaching people is the opposite of
delayed gratification which is instant
gratification and we're addicted to it
unfortunately having said that let's go
into another thing that we're addicted
to which is Adderall yes
Adderall shortage puts U.S on brink of
Public Health crisis this is an axios
story let me read this to you here with
what's going on with this the rise in
demand of Adderall has triggered
shortage of the drug raising fears that
some people can't get medicines they
rely on while many others may be
misdiagnosed a whopping 41.4 million
Adderall prescriptions were dis
dispensed in the US in 2021
up 10 from the year before getting a
diagnosis of attention deficit disorder
hyper activity disorder or ADHD which
can be treated by Adderall and other
stimulants got significantly easier
during the pandemic a wave of
telemedicine startups hit Tick Tock and
Instagram with advertisements suggesting
that people should look into ADHD
medication if they felt distracted do
you guys have strong opinions on
Adderall if you do I'm kind of curious
to know does anybody have a strong
opinions okay I mean we're giving it to
these young kids and it's it's cocaine
you know why most kids are diagnosed
with ADHD because they're not getting
enough sleep so what do you do you
prescribe with Adderall and then you
keep them up all night yeah and Pat mind
you I have every OCD I have every three
little I have HBO TPM I have every
single but I was I'm you know I'm oh
yeah I'm old school and it was just you
know and you know you know my energy you
know I'm all over the place never needed
it never took it but the people that I
am seeing it on it it's it's like my
sister's on it and you know she just
retired and it's seeing someone that
like you said it looks at their on
cocaine and then when they don't have it
it's really really weird to see that
person like you said it's just
prescribed cocaine that you're eating
instead of sniffing I could start a
podcast just talking about the
generational impact of pharmaceuticals
if you go back into the 80s and there
are two drugs that are being prescribed
by everybody's analyst translation
psychiatrist remember psychologists
won't prescribe psychiatrists well you
need a psychiatrist and it was Librium
and Valium and there is a movie that was
popular in the 80s you can all look it
up find it on Netflix I'm dancing as
fast as I can and it was a story of a
woman dealing with uh you know Valium
and Librium and things that were going
on every generation has it and you know
what Adderall is this generation we are
looking for exactly what you just said
Pat the instant microwave solution to 18
inch guns or lose 10 pounds or suddenly
feel good no calm down read a book don't
be so digital media addicted no none of
those things are or likely get some
sleep no none of those things are
reasonable give me a pill and this is
the pill of Our Generation it's
horrifying
as a parent I mean you you hear College
it's a joke within college kids in in
the meme world where it's like got a big
test tomorrow got you know got to get my
Adderall in and uh stay up all night and
study and cram for the test it's it's
just kind of become a pervasive joke uh
in the meme culture
um but what I would do like as a parent
like Tom you've got girls in high school
right yep you've got kids in elementary
school I might have a kid somewhere
you've got something somewhere in the
country like bless them that's
concerning to me I mean if you're over
18
you know I'm very big on personal
responsibility yes there's an opioid
epidemic it's sad it sucks but you know
those are the choices you make I'd be
very concerned about what 14 year olds
are doing but 17 year olds are doing if
you had kids that if you got if you're a
parent with kids out there that this is
scary to me because I mean I don't
Adderall is very addictive right I mean
that's that's uh and then also what is
very addictive is tick tock tick tock is
the number one most beloved brand
amongst gen Z for long beloved yes
you're right it's the number one I mean
I think the list no question about it
absolutely as far as like um Brands go I
think it goes um
Tick Tock Discord Snapchat Instagram
cash app Spotify so on and so forth so
look look you know look what exactly
this article says
got significantly easier getting a
getting an Adderall prescription got
significantly easier during the pandemic
as a wave of telemedicine startups hit
Tick Tock and Instagram with
advertisements suggesting
people should look into ADHD medicine if
they feel distracted so you're on Tick
Tock you're already on Adderall you're
scrolling you're sitting around you're
probably addicted to porn and you're you
know in school you're in college like as
a parent I these are difficult
conversations I don't have kids that are
you know this age but these are the
types of conversations you have to have
with your kids the difference today's
parents is back in the day a kid can go
in his room with his phone or his iPad
or laptop who knows what they can find
out there when we were growing up I had
literally a [ __ ] black and white TV
in my room and I was thankful for yeah
let me tell you what happened so on
Halloween
we myself and this other family we walk
through the community and the kids run
around and they do trick or treat and me
and this guy have conversations together
doctor very successful to say very
successful not with an m with a B they
got a company with 7 000 employees
family loves each other bunch of kids
they do very well
and we're walking
uh and all of a sudden one of his kids
comes right by us and uh in a car hey
hey what's up what's up what's up great
awesome
and he says uh yeah he lost his
technology privileges for seven weeks I
said really how old is he my 16 year old
son your 16 year old son lost technology
privileges for how long seven weeks
what's technology privilege this is just
you know video games phone you know
that's what he lost was for seven weeks
why why how do you lose technology
privileges in your house in seven weeks
said it's very easy if you don't have a
straighter you you lose technology but
you don't have a straight edge so I come
back and I'm like huh interesting so
watch what I do yeah my kids are not in
high school so as a parent I'm
constantly looking to see what
strategies of parenting works I have my
own philosophies that I lead people the
way I do and then I want to also learn
from parents that do a great job
so I come to the house and I say Tico
Dylan uh would you guys I think I'm
starting to think about maybe getting an
iPhone for you guys oh my god daddy
that's awesome this this this is that so
how do we do that I mean the
conversation doesn't even start if
you're not at Straight A's okay so come
on dad so you know what all night Tico
was telling me about how do I improve
social studies how do I increase he's
never gonna how do I improve social I
got to improve my social studies great
because in our house math is like a
regular thing you guys know this we do
math like with our eyes because we love
the game and reading all that stuff is
natural to us
if when you're saying parents that are
dealing with this when one of my kids
was going to school and the school
brought my my me and Jen to the school
and this and we need to talk to you so
what's going on your kid has a hard time
paying attention so I'm like think think
I know where they're going but just
because I wanted to know how they're
going to lead me into prescribing my
kids uh medication so I said let me let
you lead me because I want to learn okay
on how you're gonna and I'm gonna say no
but I want to learn your process yeah
yeah go for it well we think we need to
recommend you to see this doctor I said
no problem we'd love to see her so we go
to her and they do the assessment we
like to Adrenaline we like to do the
assessment with your kid so I go and is
it okay if we do the uh assessment with
your kid without you guys being in a
room is there a camera yeah we can put a
camera you can do it as long as there's
a camera and I can see it okay go for it
boom there's a great thing comes out uh
she now your kid has a hard time paying
attention and this is going to really
help him with his grades so what are you
suggesting we think we need to suggest
such and such and such and such I said
awesome I said do you by any chance
think maybe extremely creative people or
like that and have been like that for
many years and they never took anything
I mean Beethoven Mozart all these
artists all these folks that we buy and
admire and all they didn't have any kind
of stuff to take well that's the
benefits of advanced you know medicine
and you're able to ask oh okay fantastic
I said yeah if you think your this kid
has issues he's like his dad his dad was
just like that as well he's going to be
all right nope we're not going to take
any medication we went home they make
the recommendation on the you know uh
all this stuff so we go home so this
becomes today for me it's we all have
some of us have a bigger addictive
personality than others my concern isn't
just ritalin or Adderall my concern is
again going back to I want an instant
gratification solution now rather than
figuring out a way to control it you
know the other day I'm at the Angelo's
in Agatha you know who Agatha is Agatha
comes up she says hey you know Michelle
made this uh coffee for you a server
you're saying yeah yeah and he says he
wants you to try this coffee and I'm
like I don't do coffee buddy I say I
don't drink coffee she says you don't
drink coffee says no I don't drink
coffee it's a chance like ajinkoff and
Mario's like of course I drink coffee so
they drink this cup of the day yeah so
she again it goes to how come you don't
drink coffee yeah it's the last time I
drank coffee I was 25 years old if I
drink coffee you don't even want to know
what happens to me I don't want to know
what happens to me most likely I'll
drink in my 50s but not yet biggest fear
addictive personality so when you see
Solutions like this
um had a very serious relationship with
a girl but she was addicted to this and
because of that I broke up with her we
moved on no joke what was going to
school had great grades fantastic we had
a great time to together great chemistry
but she was hooked on this I just said I
can't do it because if you can't drop
this you can have other things do you
have conversations with whether it's
folks within PHP whether it's folks
within you know the school we have
people who take adderall and PHP I'm
saying the kids
and I know there's people that say I
know adults are taking it again if
you're 18 plus do you I'm talking about
10 year olds 12 year olds 14 16 year
olds are you having conversations with
parents whose kids have been prescribed
this and taking it of course so what are
they saying it's a sensitive topic you
you can only give your philosophy in a
gentle way but the adult the parent has
to make the decision you can't add a
conversation with a parent the other day
and I said listen can I make a
recommendation your kids got F's and
this kid gets everything he wants from
you guys he's gonna keep getting F's
because you have no standards and and so
well can you talk to our kids I said no
I'm not going to talk to your kid why
not I said because as much as I talk to
your kid you're his parents you're still
going to accept low standards me having
a conversation with your kid means
nothing if the standard doesn't stop
with you because I can say whatever I
want to say this kid's not in my house I
don't regulate the law you do and you're
okay with it so even if you talk to
parents if the parent's gonna say but
Patrick doesn't understand maybe you're
right then go at it that's your method
of leading I refuse to lead that way we
lead in a different way parents still
have a responsibility on what they do
with their kids as a parent how do you
what's it called this a trophy culture
what's it called you know this
essentially instant gratification where
if you're in last place you still get a
trophy what's that called participation
participation trophies so if that's one
end of the spectrum hey whatever you
want you'll get hey last place that's
fine how do you grapple that with hey
like how I was tough love like the the
example you gave with Dylan hey you can
open some of your gifts but not all of
them by the way hope you opened up the
one I gave it was a kitten so hope you
open up that one okay
so hopefully that was open
just stop two days ago exactly so how do
you how do you that's true you can't say
a funny joke and just keep saying keep
it moving by the way it was a pure bed
anyway keep going but you know like
because I have a nephew I care very much
about about you know and I'm in this
kid's life even more than ever now right
so I'm learning as well I don't have a
kid but I've got a 10 year old nephew
just turned 10. and this is something
that I'm aware of and I'm I'm taking
more of an active role and I've
obviously all my friends got kids and
I'll get there some way shout out to the
ladies out there
um but how do you grapple with this
instant gratification participation
trophy get what you want culture with
tough love wait your turn you know not
myopic approach to raising kids
long-term Investments how do you what
like how do you grapple with that like
so you're saying some of your parents
some of these parents because give the
kids whatever they want 9 30. I'm
playing dominoes with my kids and we're
talking [ __ ] to each other I love it and
we're having a freaking blast Dylan beat
me he's not three nights ago 4 15 to 275
he beat me in dominoes and no this is
not without help this kid and then Tico
beat me a couple nights ago and I'm
pretty good at dominoes and so you still
spend the time with them you still have
fun with them you still have a
relationship with them you know and they
appreciate that you know the other day
I'm uh disciplined in Tico and I'm
having a conversation with them then we
get in the car he says hey Dad can I
tell you something I'm like yeah what's
up he says I know you disciplined me and
you're tough but you know what I like
about what you do I said what he says
you're very fair so it doesn't bother me
I'm like I feel like I'm talking to him
you're 10 years old man
yeah you're tough but you're fair but go
open another job go inside get another
feed
yeah open cat get the cat but look
listen we talked about this a few weeks
ago parenting is very hard it's not easy
marriage is very hard it is Adam it's
very easy to be single and dating a new
girl every weekend that's not hard to do
that's easy bro I'm telling you right
now we had this conversation you and I
we we've been having these types of
conversation it's very easy especially
when you're older to be with 28 year
olds and 27 year olds that is not hard
to do that is easy game as we're around
around longer that gets easier and
easier and easier you get richer you get
more famous I'm sure you go to the clubs
everyone recognizes your face oh my God
this oh my God that oh my God Tate oh my
God this for me I had to at one point
make a decision what I want to do and I
just have to tell you this I chose hard
because choose an easy sucks and it's
only temporary benefits
hard to me is what let's choose what
heart is what's hard heart is staying in
shape that's not easy you're in shape
you're always in shape if we go to the
house and we've got a pool party you
take your shirt off you're always in
shape what's hard hardest exercise in
the morning being flexible and
stretching that's hard hard is what
having your finances in order that's
hard hard is always having your hygiene
together you always smell good you
always take care of yourself thank you
by the way no no what I'm trying to
that's not easy bro that's hard hard is
I don't want to buy a car I'm going to
stay disciplined that's hard bro what
you're doing that's not easy heart is
I'm not gonna go buy this temptation
this this your your gray black white
that's your colors your colors are gray
black white very easy whoever date you
is going to have a very easy time buying
gifts just go to the gray black white
section right
but Heart is also parenting Heart is
also marriage Heart is also running a
business Heart is also trying to improve
yourself that is very very very very
hard but the return is a million times
better than the return of it being easy
it's so much of a bigger return and so
so for us when you're saying all this
stuff man yeah it's it's not easy
raising kids it's not easy being married
it's not easy and doing all that stuff
but the fruits of your labor are
freaking Priceless and Pat just going
off for just I hate to go backwards but
when you're talking about you with the
with uh Tico and going to the the school
and you already knew you knew the
process was about to happen they're
going to bring them in there they're
gonna recommend yeah do you think two I
have two things to say one is there any
incentive with them doing that from like
pharmaceutical companies like are they
kind of In Cahoots because it seems like
clockwork that it's like oh he can't
focus boom automatically they're
prescribing John tomcamp is there any is
there any linkage there we talked about
this we've talked about this on the
podcast uh probably three times in the
last six teams okay we've been here with
home team
where is the only country on Earth
actually one of only two or three New
Zealand is the other one that's right
that allow
Pharmaceuticals to advertise and Market
you know just like regular people only
us and New Zealand that can promote like
stuff like that like if you know how you
see these commercials like these things
and be careful with this if this this
happens go see Dr Cialis yeah it's only
in America New Zealand side effects
include maybe two countries selling
drugs over the there's only two
countries where you can spend ad dollars
to advertise drugs wow us and New
Zealand it's only two I didn't I had no
idea that's crazy that's crazy so so
these advertising dollars yeah by the
way who do you think spends the most
money on a lobbyist can you pull up
which which industry spends
uh like Pfizer communication is one of
them big Pharma is one of them uh uh uh
financials got to be there but at the
Top If you type in biggest spending
lobbyists yeah okay pull up the
industries look at number one and it's
not even close look at that farmers of
the number one 357 billion you know what
that is that's not that's that's a lot
of money you're talking about right
that's how much they spent every year
lobbying that's insane and those I I
believe the United States was the only
country and we can look this up Tyler
the only country that gave the vaccine
makers immunity of the first year of
introduction of a drug remember yep that
we gave him Federal immunity from from
side effects so it's the vaccine makers
that's what it is because what has
happened in America is a very simple but
profound shift
medications used to be looked as
treatment and root to a cure
medications in America when you start
advertising become problem solving that
is very different in the mind of a
consumer the Cialis commercial with the
older gentleman and the woman sitting in
those um bathtubs looking out at an old
folks home looking out over a Green
Valley it's problem solving right of
course you convincing you have a problem
hey you're old you'd like still to be
bouncing around like when you were 25
that's a problem for you you're right I
have that problem so now it's problem
solving so we've moved from treatment to
cure
you know the noble purpose of medicine
do no harm all the way over to problem
solving and that is in the American
culture and it's driven by the
advertising and the pharmaceutical
industry that is actively looking out to
produce products exactly not treatments
and it's a very subtle difference but
ladies and gentlemen the United States
of America pharmaceutical industry yeah
and Todd before and I want you to say
what you're going to say but and you
know people what none of us even talked
about all that Adderall all that Ritalin
all that you know your serotonin
somebody explained to me one of my
friends was Doctor to explain to me in
layman's term you have happy juice in
your brain you only have a certain
amount for the rest of your life
Adderall and all this stuff diminishes
that it depletes it and you never get
that that juice back and that's why a
lot of these people tell her they they
those kids those are a lot of mass
Shooters if you want to be real big then
something's got to be real small yeah
100 but you're on top there has to be a
statistic of all these Mass Shooters and
all these suicides and it's all kids
that were on Adderall and all these mine
and altering medications that nobody
wants to talk about but that those kids
are all on these drugs what do you want
to talk about well you know it comes
down to this and don't let Pat go to
another topic here consequence and
discipline yeah what Pat was just
talking about discipline it's hard it
takes discipline it takes discipline to
do something and and consequences is the
best way to raise kids there's a million
techniques out there but consequences
I'll give you two great examples you
know the girls this year the school has
an uh iPad which is programmed with all
the school stuff they turn in their
homework and you can't get access to
certain internet stuff it literally is
an electronic book with proper guard
rails around it but also I have to pay
for it and I also have to pay for a 120
dollar apple pencil
and I told Brooke I said that apple
pencil is 120 don't lose it why 11 year
old sixth grade I'm predicting guess
what she was on a plane with me and I
always say here we're getting ready to
land pack your stuff up pack your stuff
up she had that pencil in the pocket in
front gone she left the pencil on the
plane when we got home she realized that
it wasn't there
I had a backup pencil above the
refrigerator and I put it down and I
said for 125 dollars you can do your
homework
that's what she said and she goes to her
savings account and I say give me
permission to transfer it oh wow I
whipped out the banking app and I
transferred 125 dollars to basically the
family checking that we use for casual
expenses Bing
next Bailey golf tournament for school
goes for a practice round leaves the
range finder which you've ever seen golf
range finder like 300 bucks in the cart
Bailey's usually really really tight
about this stuff far more anal than her
sister
and she got busy she was talking to her
teammates and stuff left it there next
day going to play Mom I forgot my
Rangefinder and Kim is like wow um I
guess you're going to play this round
without it because we're here in Orlando
for a tournament and I am not going to
drive 80 miles an hour to a Dick's
Sporting Goods it might be open right
now and be the parachute helicopter
parent that saves you from consequence
she played the round without it played
fine was discipline and they went that
afternoon and they bought one with whose
money her money
Brooke
how much did that cost Bailey listen to
that statement how much did that cost
Bailey Brook knew the rule right
unfortunately the Pro Shop calls back
hey lost and found they turned it in got
the receipt she got it back but the
point was at no point did Bailey think
she was not on the hook for that
consequence no it's tough to do but you
got to do it you have to have the will
to I want to do one last and we move on
because we got a bunch of others quick
point I think and I I what Pat said was
just so on point I think what you what
you essentially were talking about
especially with the medicine and the
drugs it's preventative versus reactive
you know Bill Maher you know kind of his
like Awakening red pill was like during
covid everything was like you know the
vaccine whatever is the was the easy fix
but what nobody talks about is get your
fat ass out there and lose some weight
get out and get some sun work out be
healthy feel healthy get out there and
play the fact that they shut down Parks
was insane to me shutdown beaches was
insane to me looking back at it not to
go all conspiracy theory on it but like
insane but like physical mental
emotional when you're talking physical
we talked about steroids quick fix some
steroids it's a lot harder to get your
ass in the gym every single day or like
I do I do yoga every single morning and
I stretch it's a lot harder to do that
right and you're talking about that's
physical mental talked about Adderall
it's a lot harder to sit down and buckle
down and read and do what you got to do
it's a lot easier to just take some
Adderall boom bang out 24 hours of study
and take your test sleep for a couple
days you know an emotional I mean
antidepressants Prozac it's a lot easier
to just take a happy pill let's just
keep everything butterflies are great
it's a lot harder to like look in the
mirror and kind of improve yourself so
the the harder things like with the
Milton Friedman talked about what's easy
and hard when it comes to printing money
and use the analogy of what alcoholism
the it's a lot easier to take the Quick
Fix to take the pill it's a lot harder
to put in the work most people don't
want to put in the work so that's why
you get the ramifications of the easy
way and nobody wants to talk about sorry
just real quick the same people that are
making the Band-Aids are making the
bullets Bears make an aspirin to make
you feel better who does bear own
Monsanto what does Monsanto make Roundup
what is Roundup Heaven glyphosate
glyphosate is a forever chemical that's
killing people the same people that make
the Band-Aids are making the bullets hey
Gillian dialectic this is not a new
thing this has been going on for a long
time by the way let me just put this out
there U.S FBI director says Tick Tock
possesses
possess National Security concerns this
is a reuter story the U.S operations of
Chinese owned Tick Tock raise National
Security concerns FBI director Chris Ray
said on Tuesday flagging the risk that
the Chinese government could harness the
video sharing app to influence users and
control their devices risks include the
possibility that the Chinese government
could use tick tock to control data
collection on Millions users control the
recommendation algorithms for influence
on operations Ray noted Chinese
companies are required to essentially do
whatever the Chinese government wants
them to do uh in terms of sharing
information of serving as a tool of the
Chinese government and so that that's
plenty of Reason by itself to be
extremely concerned now you may say Pat
we just heard the story a couple weeks
ago that was CIA this is FBI you know
what's next one president away from Tick
Tock being banned in the U.S and those
users are going to go to either Twitter
or Instagram or snap and that benefits
those three other companies hence why I
believe that is an opportunity for Elon
that he sees and he smells and he's
taken advantage of the next story a lot
of Americans are no longer tipping uh 20
percent it's adjusting and that's
another sign by the way I want to go
through this fairly quickly uh are
Americans reaching a Tipping Point when
it comes down to well tipping that could
be the big takeaway from the recent
survey that signal a possible shift in
attitudes about gratitudes uh uh one
survey from uh Pompano a restaurant tech
company found a decline in the
percentage of consumers who say they tip
20 or more restaurants from 56 in 2021
to 43 this year that's a decline of 13
another survey from play USA a website
that covers online gambling found that
60 of Americans said they would like to
do away with tipping all together and go
European style what's behind the
sentiment
inflation appears to be playing a role
the U.S the play USA survey based on the
response of a thousand six people noted
that 17 of Americans said they were
tipping less due to Rising costs do you
remember a year and a half ago they were
talking about how people are tipping
more they're doing 25 something percent
now it's going backwards again this is
another sign while people are sitting
there saying okay instead of tipping you
19 I'm gonna only tip you sixteen
dollars three dollars may not seem like
a lot of money but they're actually
thinking about it yeah I mean well it
kind of goes to the story about in 2020
more people were paying off debt now
there are more people are accumulating
debt I'll tell you a crazy story so uh I
eat this sushi restaurant in South Beach
we've eaten there moshi moshi I've named
my freaking cats Moshi and miso after
this freaking restaurant it's my
favorite restaurant love it it's open
till 5 a.m so like oh wow you leave a
club go get some sushi so I go I get the
I go to sit down I'm with a lady friend
of mine we have a bite and uh the waiter
comes up gives up some Waters I was like
all right can we put in some appetizers
she goes yeah yeah it's on the you gotta
just do it on the app now I said well
you're right here I'll just can I get
some miso soups yeah nope you got to do
it on the app I'm like I gotta download
the app you're here I'm talking to you
it's like the scene in the 40 year old
version when he's like came into the
store he's like I'd like to buy these
shoes she's like you gotta buy it on
eBay he's like I'm here in front of you
I would just like to buy them off of you
I had the most awkward exchange with
this guy I'm like I would like to order
sushi sorry do it on the app I'm like
I'm talking to you in your face bro so
we go through this whole song and dance
I do the whole app thing and then at the
end of the day he goes yeah you know I
put my card in there and I pay and I go
all right uh there's no option to give
you a tip he's like yeah we don't we
don't do tips anymore don't do tips
anymore what so the restaurant that I've
eaten at more than probably any
restaurant Miami no longer has a server
that serves you you have to do an on the
app okay and now when all is said and
done the restaurant has shut down
tipping they also canceled ginger
dressing which I almost freaked out so
is the price of the sushi going on the
price I don't know if it did or I might
have because inflation but yeah but
things are changing like you're
recognizing these things that are
happening very interesting so but this
is a restaurant that I've eaten at a
hundred plus times and all of a sudden
they deviated I'll tell you one more
thing the most awkward thing ever right
now is going and paying doing your Apple
pay tap they flip the screen around it
says here would you like to do a tip
yeah and it gives you 10 15 20 25 it's
like I just bought a Starbucks bro like
I'm like I'm not tipping you [ __ ] okay
and they're like oh really okay
oh really zero zero his tipping culture
is getting very weird out there these
days that's just as awkward like you go
to CVS and then you're finished and they
go do you want to give a dollar to a
starving kid
you know I went to Australia this is my
first experience with this I went to
Australia this is uh you know 20 2009
2010
there's no tipping whatsoever but they
pay the employees this was the I don't
know the double minimum wage so they're
paying employees 25 bucks an hour where
they pay you you know 12 bucks an hour
here whatever the number is and but
there's no tipping but when there's no
tipping that means don't expect great
service of course right like there's the
ying and the Yang the risk and the
reward so if there's no accountability
in the service of the restaurant why
would you need to tip so yeah things go
down I like tipping you know what tip
stands for
tip is an Ackerman stands for to ensure
prompt service oh wow it was given in
advance wow oh wow that's great it's
become a posture action
early days it was to ensure prompt
service well you gave a couple dollars
to get a table it was an engineer prompt
service I appreciated that you
pre-appreciate it that's awesome well I
know Vinnie you play a game
that's just by the way if that tip was
big enough for you what Tom just said
give us a sub subscribe to the podcast
at 500 now we want to do celebration
yeah live podcast with you help us get
there I know a lot of you guys say I
prefer home team than doing the
interviews we combine both of them I
like doing both of them but if you enjoy
our home team model here uh give us a
sub also at the same time this gold
signature series is coming out this gold
Signature Series valuetainment merch is
coming out on Black Friday and Cyber
Monday also a numbered series coming
where you're able to buy numbered hats
only numbered to 200 there's only going
to be 200 these will be limited editions
being sold on eBay you'll see that but
the gold signature series comes out
on Black Friday and Cyber Monday if you
haven't yet registered to be the first
to know because it's going to sell out
like this text the word merch m-e-r-c-h
text award merge to
310-340-1132 once again merch
m-e-r-c-h-310-340-1132 you'll be the
first to know about the gold merch
that's limited and the numbered ones are
gonna go like in no time but you'll be
the first to know we're going to send a
text to you first before it goes public
and you'll be able to take advantage of
the gold Signature Series that's coming
out Cyber Monday I can't wait for it
gold VT logos cyber Mondays win it's
coming up next couple weeks so it's the
day it's the Monday after Thanksgiving
weekend yeah yeah please tell me we're
doing what we did 100 we're gonna do
people that buy Signature Series the
first 50 I'm gonna FaceTime them oh it's
okay we're gonna call together no joke
we did it at your house that was in
Dallas
all right so is it time to go into the
Trump uh topics yeah what a first hour
let's move on to something else let's go
let's go let's go Trump let's go Trump
okay all right so uh where do we go from
here with Trump all right let me just
where can we go meaning which story do I
read I know so first of all
um did you watch the speech or did you
watch Snippets of the speech what did
you do watch Snippets Snippets okay yes
Vinnie you watch those I watched this
how long was the speech by the way oh uh
hour and seven minutes uh something like
that ain't nobody got time I was
actually talking with uh Tyler yesterday
it's funny I mean I knew we were going
to talk about it but the fact that he
didn't he I feel like somebody sat him
down and was like listen Donald if they
didn't call him Trump didn't call him
president do not go after anybody stay
in your lane don't talk about election
fraud don't talk about any of that [ __ ]
something is Shifting Pat well I think
somebody's in his ear going if we're
going to win and somebody like a
DeSantis is going to run don't be that
guy got him he didn't talk about the
sentence he didn't bring up no he kind
of hinted at certain [ __ ] I know he said
something about paper ballots which I
think you know whatever you know I mean
go go to vote I want to see the person
in person but I think somebody talked to
him and let him know like calm down and
don't be the crazy Trump that that we
all know okay I think it'll help I think
it helped so first of all I watched the
whole thing yeah and I want to kind of
give you what things uh uh I liked and
what seemed different about it okay so
here's here's what I like this is this
is what's going to get people's
attention now when you if you watch
media if you watch CNN and if you watch
Fox you're gonna get two different takes
I want this I've watched more CNN videos
this week than I've watched in a long
time I don't know how much CNN I've
consumed this week I've consumed a lot
of CNN because I want to know what
they're going to be saying I want to
know fully where they're going to be
saying from the other side okay so a few
things that he talked about he said
Economic Security is National Security
that line I thought was the most
powerful line he gave Economic Security
is National Security meaning if the
economy doing well we're fine if the
economy is not doing well that's a
national security well the economy is
taking a hit right now hence National
Security he talked about fentanyl which
what a lot of parents are concerned
about and that's a real issue that
people are actually worried about
um
he says the moment I get elected Catch
and Release will be gone forever a lot
of people in New York in San Francisco
and many you know cities they're all for
that being gone so the moment I get
elected Catch and Release will be gone
forever uh he'll safely remove illegal
aliens that's what he said going back to
what he said in 2015 human trafficking
has been a worse in human history that
is a concern of a lot of people no man
will participate in women's support his
words no man will participate in women's
sports I said support both Sports thank
you no man will participate in women's
sports guess what that's both sides of
the aisle people are saying I kind of
you know the Democrat Republic even
Democrats are now starting to say this
just doesn't make any sense every
soldier that got fired for not taking
the vaccine will get an apology letter
and back pay that is going to resonate
there's 33 million veterans that's going
to resonate with a lot of them who got
fired schools will lose Federal funding
if they push CRT and gender Insanity
great message that's going to resonate
with a lot of parents ban insider
trading for politicians a lot of people
are wondering what happened when Nancy
Pelosi going from zero to a couple
hundred million dollars I wonder exactly
what happened to eliminate cheating in
elections I will eliminate I will uh
demand voter ID same day voting and only
paper ballots that's a lot of people are
for that from his side of the aisle and
then National greatness agenda you know
going back to it now there's a couple
different things those are the policies
for me I like policies because that's
how he won so how he lost is one is like
well you know election production this
election that election that that's how
he lost okay I mean was that's how you
lose yeah that's not the way to to to
win when you're just talking about a
snapper Snapper Snapper that's how
Hillary lost the first time Hillary's
campaign was what I'm with her her whole
campaign was around let's have a female
to become a president people are like
look I'm not with it man you're not that
exciting to be honest with you you're
whatever to me you're just I don't see
your any policies it was only about I'm
with her he's a bad guy vote for me
versus Trump won because he actually
talked policies he went back to his
Playbook that worked which is talking
policies fentanyl policy economic
security policy you know Catch and
Release policy illegal aliens policy
human trafficking policy no man uh
participating women's sport policy every
soldier that got fired get the apologies
letter for vaccine and back pay policy
schools losing Federal funding if they
push the rtj policy ban Insider training
for politicians policy uh demanding
voter ID same-day voting and paper
ballots policy all of these things are
policy okay so now let me give you the
other side of it when I watched it
uh some parts with the energy is what I
felt okay that I don't think is going to
work well if you run angry angry doesn't
work when a sales leader is running
angry sales people quit and they don't
sell sales people don't do well when the
sales leader is angry you know I I a man
one time many years ago said this and I
thought it was a great quote he told me
man named money that stuck with me till
today very very successful man out of
Utah he said
um he said a a little bit of fire in the
house keeps it warm too much far in the
house burns the house down meaning every
once in a while your kids need to know
that is capable but every 90 days but if
it's every day that you're raising your
voice then you're gonna burn the house
down if a sales leader is constantly
pissed off at his people you know how
come you're not doing this okay I'm so
disappointed that's just too much every
quarter when a sales leader is a little
bit challenging and pushing his people
it's like okay cool I can see that we
have it Trump can not come out angry
it's not inspirational he has to look
like he's having fun he has to look like
it's it's a enjoying the process he
didn't look like he was having fun
that's one thing that I saw where it
seemed like it was just business where
in 2015 to me he felt like he was having
fun while he's doing and I understand
it's serious I understand it say this is
not a fun politics it's not fun I
totally get it but you have to get
people to laugh you have to get people
to say okay I'm seeing this guy's energy
the other thing that I felt was the
following
his daughter played a big role in the
last election for her to announce the
day after I'm not going to be a part of
it and she just flat out came out and
says look I'm not I'm not doing any
politics you know I'm gonna help out but
I'm not doing any politics I'm not
moving forward uh where's the story
about Ivanka If You Can Tell me uh page
four yeah if you want to read it just
read the so I love my father very much
this time around I'm choosing to
prioritize my young children and the
private life we are creating as a family
I do not plan to be involved in politics
says Ivanka Trump now that's one person
that had influence over Dad where Dad
would actually pay attention the main
person I agree and then also her husband
Jared what Jared may be involved you
don't know if Jared's gonna be involved
or not and some people are saying he was
present when the message was given some
said he saw him some say they didn't see
him I don't know if he was there or not
and think about it past sheet think
about it think about what her entire
family went through for that four years
I mean every time you saw her it was
something investigator they're corrupt
dude at that point right now she's like
I'm not doing this again I don't think
it has anything to do with her father
and that's I'm obviously it does but
like with the media and you already know
what's going to start happening or it
started it's it's already starting all
the group chats from my cousins and my
friends it's already Trump this he's
it's like bro it's I I don't think she
wants to by the way Ivanka hung out with
Kim Kardashian a couple weeks ago yeah I
saw that so maybe she's like look man I
want to go back to just being that girl
who was sexy attractive had a brand on
building companies I'm building
businesses I don't want to be doing
politics this or by the way I think
she's going to have a career in politics
for sure 100 I just don't think she
wants to do it right now and a couple
other things I'll say and I'll open it
up for commentary here here's the
concerns okay where people are wondering
if he can still win without the
following number one
um Stephen Schwartzman just flat out
came out and said I won't be back in
another Trump run if you don't know who
Steven Schwartzman is he is just pull up
with Steven Schwartzman is he wrote one
of the best books I read I highly
recommend any businessman is that black
rock oh he Stephen Schwartzman is uh uh
zooming a little bit CEO of Blackstone
and his net worth is 30 billion dollars
this is not a lightweight guy and he's a
Republican and he went against Obama so
this is not just a rhino Republican this
guy's a heavyweight okay so some may
call him a rhino I don't know if I would
put him as a rhino I just think he's a
business guy that's saying Trump I'm not
going to back up another one Ken Griffin
came out and called Trump a three-time
loser uh they're wondering if Fox is
going to support him with the Murdoch
backing him up every day talking about
him Hannity did uh I don't know if
Tucker's gonna do that I don't know if
others are going to do that I think on
Fox they're split between DeSantis and
Trump so there are some that are just
going behind the scientists and they're
public about it and some that are still
loyal to DeSantis like a Hannity I don't
think uh Tucker's gonna be one that's
going to go and endorse 100 either or
he's just gonna do his part he doesn't
have Twitter so you have to keep him on
Twitter's not there uh Ivanka is not
going to be there this time around
junior is still a part of it he has a
bunch of people that are going to be
supporting but not the same thing as he
did before 4 and then
last but not least when you're going on
a run and you're announcing a run the
Run isn't being announced after a
victory the run is being announced after
a loss so so they were expecting this
speech to be a different speech which
the speech was here's what we now carry
a lake and we sung you know and let me
to Arizona and the Nevada he didn't have
that that he was expecting to have when
he gave that message that is felt and he
said something jokingly in uh at the end
of it's like 55 minutes into it where he
says yeah can we have this person stand
up hey we have to give it up to the
first lady she's so amazing what she
does you know sometimes I come home and
she says well uh Donald he says don't
talk to me I'm not in the mood right now
he joked but it was it was actually a
cool joke I like it it humanized to say
yeah you're actually willing to
self-deprecate a little bit because
typically you don't hear the
self-deprecation from this guy and I'll
finish it up with this okay I'll finish
it up with this I'll finish it up with
this
at this point they asked the scientists
what do you got to say about Trump he
says listen man chill out you guys got
to chill out this just happened we're
doing this we're doing that and he did
take a shot as well the sentence I don't
know if you caught it or not what the
Santa said Tyler did you catch what the
Santa said he said check the scoreboard
he said yeah he says look I think what
we need to focus on right now is the run
in uh Georgia the Senate run on George
off with Churchill Walker Republicans
have to do says look obviously it wasn't
good everywhere across the board for
Republicans Florida was a different
story than everywhere else for
Republicans that's a shot to say my
state we all won yeah the other guy not
everybody won so we're gonna see what's
gonna happen that was indirectly a shot
at Trump I understand smack talking that
was a bit of a subtle shot to say my
record is the following I don't know
about the other guy's record here's my
record so and Patrick we'll see what's
going to happen now so question uh so
now Trump trump announced because I
don't really know the history of it but
like what when do other Republicans that
are trying to run kind of step forward
and they say like what how long does
that take does that take another year
because Trump right now is off and
running and I saw some uh some report
that Obama on his second run had I guess
only 60 million dollars or something in
donors uh Trump has like 90 like 94 or
like it's it's ridiculous for people
people do to people to assume Trump
jumps down he doesn't have a chance to
much of the Sanchez don't don't let the
media lie to you bro Trump is in good
shape and he has a lot of people behind
him I'm just curious so when when would
we hear if like a DeSantis is going to
run how long here's the other part
though here's the other part where the
question now is why is he announcing so
soon so the reason why he announced so
soon one hey if he's running they indict
him it's going to be like look they're
trying to take me down they're afraid of
me so some people are saying that's why
he went too soon the second thing is
it's not smart to go this early because
everybody else is probably not going to
announce for another I don't know six to
nine months which means everyone else
can watch to see how they attack Trump
so for three six nine months they're
gonna watch the media try to attack and
Destroy Trump that's going to give so
much Intel for the next person that's
going to be announcing to run because
either this is going to be a great play
that he made going early or it's going
to backfire because you want a little
too early that's the question a lot of
people are having okay could we make it
just really fast can we make like let's
set today's date what's what's CNN stock
at or whatever what other companies and
let's see how the rate or the ratings
let's see how much it goes up like from
today uh because now that Trump is in
now let's let's see the shift because
he's gonna save their the channel is the
parent company Time Warner or who is it
is it Tom Maloney whoever Melania my
heart I heart iHeart let's just know
what all the viewers let's today's
rediscovery yeah yeah yeah
current company who owns Discovery at
John Malone no who's the what's the
what's the stock what does it all come
under yeah I think
I'm basically saying look at their
ratings right now watch how much they're
gonna go from today because he announced
now it's gonna be the Trump [ __ ] show
you'll see I I'm telling you Tyler what
do you think
uh I think somebody put a leash on him
and gave him some really good advice uh
because I did not see it and I want to
go re-watch it so I can see all the the
emotional Nuance that was in it but I
read the text and I said this didn't
seem trumpian of the last 18 months
trumpian the last 18 months was bitter
accusatory I've been robbed you know
like the uh
like a great player with a bad attitude
that complains about the refs for the
next two days is why they got eliminated
in the championship and then everybody
forgets well then why did it come down
to game seven why didn't you clean these
guys out before two calls by a ref could
take away your ring
um I felt like it wasn't as trumpian as
we've seen in the last two years but I
agreed with you I saw some things in
there that I thought were wow that is a
positive policy that's a positive I was
thinking of platform you know you put
your planks in the platform to run and I
saw a balanced approach to build a
platform trying to bring together the
Republican Civil War on a lot of issues
I felt like there was a leash on him but
I didn't see the emotion behind it or
the energy behind it but I I really felt
wow this is not the bitter guy so
someone is the bitter guy gone I don't
think so so somebody that he trusts
talked him into or got his head around
this this line of discussion but I want
to go see all the emotional bits and I
want to watch the whole thing and done
so did he announce this that's not to
cut you off did he announce his campaign
manager yet who's the I know Lewandowski
was one of the ones from the last one I
don't know about campaign that'd be a
good I want to find out whoever that
person is is talking good but I'm
watching the comments here and Chris
made a really good point that I was
gonna make the same one this is a
campaign speech what does he do in the
rallies great he's reserved he's calm
he's collected for the campaign speech
fantastic I think that's great what does
he do in the rallies what does he do if
he's back on Chris from Super Chat
just a regular guy
I guarantee he's gonna he's gonna go off
the road you're seeing the Trump family
come out you're seeing former campaign
Staffing former campaign managers you're
seeing former Chiefs of Staff I think
people are just kind of tired of the
Whirlwind that is Donald Trump that's a
good question what does he do Pat when
he's got the you know you pull energy
from an audience the audience throws
energy to to you and then you energize
and then you extemporaneously go on does
he go into and Nancy Pelosi is a
disaster you know does he suddenly go
down there's something worse it's a
trumpian but what's wrong with that no
there's nothing wrong with that see
what's wrong with him saying Nancy that
Nancy Pelosi is a disaster no no there's
an audience that agrees with that what's
wrong with him saying what what is the
issue that he shouldn't do isn't that he
should continue doing that that's his
brand like his brand is that what what
isn't attractive with his brand is what
he did the last two years
that's what's not attractive I would
tell you right now if he didn't go that
route for the last two years
continuously I am a victim Pompeo what
did Pompeo call him pompeare said he's
acting like a you know Pompeo appears to
take aim at uh Trump for looking
backwards and claiming victimhood calls
for serious leaders right okay so that's
what Pompeo just said guess what Pompeo
wants to do he also wants one wants to
run what is not attractive is the
victimhood didn't work for Hillary it
doesn't work for anybody in business it
doesn't work it's just not attractive
period when you take that doesn't work
for anybody Victor mental zero it's not
a good look yeah there's another
giveaway when you call Elon Musk a
[ __ ] artist or you make these
unnecessary enemies look at you made
this point eloquently uh with uh
Blagojevich and Kerry Lake when she went
after the CNN reported she said she's
more DeSantis than she is trumpian I
don't know the way the way she carries
herself and speaks I think that's a
really key point that you can still go
out I'd love to have a one hour sit down
one-on-one with uh uh Donald Trump and
just ask him a set of questions I think
it'd be a very fair interview I would
want to ask him certain set of questions
that no one's asked them there's a
certain set of questions that no one has
yet asked them it's not a gotcha
question it's not any of that stuff it's
you know it's it's certain set of
questions that I have for for the guy
but you know going back to what you're
saying uh some people are saying well is
it going to go back to that yes he is
yeah so so what do you think is that
like a negative thing he can go back to
that all day long make people laugh be
sarcastic do what he does and what he's
been like for 76 years or 77 years what
is not going to be a turn on is
victimhood mentality well and I know
Adam wants to make a point here you said
also during the Blagojevich that there's
a reason the Obama uh Bruce Springsteen
podcast didn't take off because Obama
isn't a podcast host that's not his game
right why do you think he was such a
powerful president and so respected
because he's not a podcast host right
people don't want a podcast host for a
president people don't want somebody as
outlandish and bombastic in reality
television I disagree okay I disagree no
those are two different things uh uh
those are two different things because
what people don't want to hear like with
a Obama in a Bruce Springsteen Obama
became a victim as well what are you
talking about you you people don't like
that Obama's entire Mo was look they're
doing this because I'm black that's not
attractive either I mean I'm not sitting
here taking one side or another I'm not
attracted by victimhood mentality no
matter who does it okay no matter who
does it I don't care if I ever get into
it like the other day we want to do The
Tick Tock video right to show it the
only thing I want to show with the tick
tock video is to say look what they did
right after the China clip and see what
happened do you know still me wanting to
make that video is uncomfortable deep
down inside because a part of it is kind
of like well you're acting like a victim
all of us tend to go there sometimes
well man I've been working so hard
lately you chose to be a seal let me
tell you all this pressure this stop
[ __ ] anyway you had kids nobody told
you to have unprotected sex let me tell
you you know how life is being a single
man you chose to become single nothing
is attractive about victimhood mentality
it's got nothing to do with Left Right
middle Center black white asian Middle
Eastern women men gay straight no one
cares stop being a victim it's not
attractive if he goes there I don't care
I'm personally not going to resonate to
that I as a man I'm not turned on by
victims if a person next to me complains
too much about white people are after
him or her when people would call and
say the following
I killed one of our guys the other day
for closeout
so that they were having a we're
watching a fight in the backyard you
know this first 20 minutes I'm on the
side I'm having to call your wife's
patented for the hooker fight yeah Tom
Collins so what happened close oh let me
tell you man you know the bamboo was
given issues
I said are you again going back to so
you're the only person that had
technology last night
I'm just naturally not attracted to
victimhood mentality I'm not so if he
goes there you're gonna see what happens
with the podcast here and what what the
feedback we're going to be given we're
not going to endorse victim with
mentality listen the moment you choose
to get into politics what has politics
been known forever dirty uh what else is
it now they're gonna Target you it's
dirty they're going to come after your
family
what then don't do it yeah you signed up
you signed up for this shitty job
there's nothing about this job that's
attractive if somebody wants to go into
politics they came after my family
that's what they do that's what critics
do their job is to come after your
family then don't go play sports LeBron
if you don't like what Stephen A says
then don't go run for office Trump if
you don't like what people say then
don't go be a media guy Obama if you
don't like what they say about you but
whatever you do don't act like a victim
it is never attractive ever attractive
in any industry is not attractive to be
honest he should just not bring up any
of the election [ __ ] just focus well to
be honest and I it's weird for me to say
I miss the entertaining Trump because
right now for the past two years it's
Joe Biden shaking hands with people that
aren't there sniffing people's hair it's
just been a [ __ ] show I do I'm not gonna
front I miss the like what the hell is
he gonna say next I agree with you 100
if he just does not bring up the
election type [ __ ] yes I I would like
the you know what we're gonna hold fauci
accountable we're gonna go after the doj
because of their their bias and what
they're doing and now Tyler showed me a
clip from uh Christopher Ray the FBI
director where they ask him in front of
Congress they said can you tell us right
now if there was for January 6 was there
any FBI agents dressed as Trump
supporters inside the capitol before the
doors were open you know what he said I
can't talk about it he's like the
congressman was like wait you can't say
no you guys didn't have anybody inside
waiting As Trump supporters and then
opening doors for these people so I want
I want to talk crap but I want
accountability and I do like all the
stuff that you said that he talked about
about the Fentanyl and the securing the
you know securing the board and all that
stuff I want that type of stuff I don't
want to go I feel bad for myself that
you you know I watched it as a Critic
and I watched it as a voter like I try
to I asked Kobe one time how do you
watch movies he says I watch movies and
I just listen to the music he said I
watch movies and I turn off the audio
just to see how they're acting then I
watched the movie I'm like what he
watches movies like that so I watch it
as a voter and I watched it as a you
know a Critic right as a voter I'm like
okay that policy I'm interested in that
policy I'm also interested in
you're going to execute on those
policies I'm interested in those
policies being executed so that part
resonated with me as a voter not as the
personality okay as a Critic I give you
my feedback as a Critic you know how we
felt you know family not being all this
other stuff but as a voter I'm like okay
if he keeps talking those policies I
think he's gonna have momentum yeah sure
um well speaking of movies
um
look he what he's trying to do right now
let me give like sort of a a measured
response you know we're gonna have
plenty of time to talk about Trump and
where we think he's gonna we're gonna
talk about this for the next two plus
years and if he wins you know six years
what have you uh what he's trying to do
is something that hasn't been done in
over 130 something years I think the
last presidential candidate to lose or
win and then lose then come back hasn't
been done since Grover Cleveland in 1888
like a few years after the Civil War
ended so what he's doing is going to be
very very unique at the same time if
anybody could do it it's probably Trump
the the challenge that he's going to
have speaking of movies it's like 2016
we had never seen this movie okay this
was so unique Trump came out of nowhere
and just boom boom Little Marco Rubio
ugly wife Ted Cruz low energy jet like
boom watch that you have to see this
must-see TV the problem is now it's like
let me think of a movie like that was
Jurassic Park now you want me to go
watch Jurassic Park 3 and get excited
about it people was like I've already
seen this movie it's like you're a
comedian it's like the comedian who's
back up there doing his old bits that
you he's been doing for 20 years it's
like kind of already seen this movie
before so like this weekend I was in now
but Dallas they give you the Wall Street
Journal for free on the Wall Street
Journal The Wall Street Journal the day
that Trump enters the race he's not even
the main story I'm like how is that
how's that possible get choked up over
here Kevin McCarthy 90 of America
doesn't even know or care about who's
gonna become the Senate I'm sorry the
House Majority Leader he was the top
story so like the papers are just like
we've been here we've seen this movie
trying to sell me on Jurassic Park 3
right now so then you have Ivanka is not
a part of it you've got all these people
like Mark esper defense secretary he's
out on him you've got you just said
Steven Schwartzman he's out on him
you've got Mick Mulvaney who was his
chief economic advisor basic saying he's
out
um who's the guy you mentioned that was
his secretary of state for a minute
Pompeo Pompeo he's out on him so it's
like who is Trump's cabinet actually
gonna be I'm wondering genuine question
but the the the the the story that we'll
constantly have to talk about is why is
Trump running at this point is it
because he wants to make America great
again again and he K or now it's again
which I don't know who told him like the
three words in the middle are yeah so
you've seen the jokes already I'm sure
like you want to gag check out this
mcgaga thing so but whatever I'm not
even being emotional does he actually
want to make America great again is that
truly truly truly his number one
incentive or is it Vengeance filled is
it raged is it getting even is it
settling the score because we all know
that Donald Trump can do one speech one
nice little speech tempered measured
someone got in his ear go give Donald
Trump the next two years of being under
control best of luck out there so
I think you know we're going to see what
happens with him I think there's a
yearning here's my final point there is
a yearning in America for a younger
fresher leader look at where DeSantis is
in the polls right now they're neck and
neck and you go I sent you the Vegas
odds yeah I was just about to ask you
you know I always go to Vegas here
forget about Republican opinions forget
about Democratic opinions Vegas knows so
if you pull up the Vegas odds I think I
sent them to you earlier Tyler
where are they right now
it goes up by just oh wow oh they're
tied they're neck and neck with 300 300.
they're above Biden did you get Kamala
and here's scary Gavin do some right
here no chance I've given my opinion on
this I could be wrong shoot me down all
day if Trump goes against a Gavin Newsom
as much as I think that Gavin Newsom is
the fakest most plastic guy ever Newsom
will beat Trump I think I think any
Republican has a shot at the White House
Trump's last on the list so so
good commentary I'll I'll give you a
couple things from my thoughts that I
agree with you number one uh the way I I
just sold PHP right insurance company
the way I led the company the first six
months to 18 months that doesn't work in
the fifth year that doesn't work in the
10th year that doesn't work after you
sell the company
the same strategy doesn't work in a
different season this is a different
season for Trump so you know as a coach
the way your team won one way you're not
going to win the same way because your
best player was a center and now your
best player is a two guard now your best
player is a point guard now your best
players are number four you're not going
to win the same way it's the coach's
ability to adjust and play with the
current players you have I don't know if
he's going to be able to do it or not
we're gonna find out this is a very
different strategy the same strategy in
2020 2016 is not going to win today
correct what is going to work in 2016 he
has to look at what worked for 2016.
what worked in 2016 is he kept talking
same policies over and over and over and
over again that worked what didn't work
in 2020 is victim they're coming after
me they're coming after me they're
coming after me they're coming after me
that didn't work so you have to kind of
make that adjustment is he gonna use
that or not we have no idea the other
thing I will tell you as well on this
and then I want to go to the Iran topic
because we only got 19 minutes left
um here's the other part the the best
part about competition and sports okay
we said this a few weeks ago when Dylan
says the Eagles are going to win it the
Eagles just ended up losing to the
commanders I was in DC they were
celebrating because there's Eagles fans
there's commanders fans and uh
way way too early right now man we have
no idea what's going to be happening the
next 18 months no idea on what's going
to be upon 18 months do not get it
twisted I guarantee you the left is
sitting on some kind of a dirt on
DeSantis the day he wins the nominee for
the Republican the next week month three
months six months they're gonna come out
with stuff against the Santas they're
gonna wait to see who's gonna be in this
election or not they're going to watch
to see who's going to run on the
Republican side or not we're going to
see who are going to be the candidates
running right now if you look at some of
the list of names that you hear about
potentially running Christy may be
running uh uh uh Nikki Haley may be
running Pompeo may be running Tim Scott
may be running uh Hutchinson may be
running Hogan may be running youngin may
be running the Santas may be running
Pence may be running there's a lot of
people that may be running on the right
it is way too early right now to be
betting on what's going to be happening
but if you're like mattress back and
you're willing to bet on the ass way
early yeah to win 75 million bucks to go
take a shot at some of these weird guys
like put put put a grant on Hillary
you'd be surprised because she's the
person that she could somehow creep up
in there and if she gets facing off
against somebody she may end up winning
if you if you're if you're the type of
person that goes to races and bets on
the horse that's one to 99. put it back
on Hillary put a buck on uh uh the rock
put 10 bucks on Michelle because those
are some of the wild cards I'll go I'll
go with you I'm because listen I swear
to God yeah if we put collectively us
for we put a thousand on Newsome and
that and he wins that's 16 G's I'm if
you're down I'll do it no because wait
wait wait because who's gonna out of all
the of all the Democrats I can't believe
Joe Biden's up there closer over
newsom's over Kamala Harris what a comma
is above um first of all think about the
DNC kamahara says no chance I think
you're under something and it's it's not
who has no chance it's who will the DNC
allow to get access to the large bucket
of Soros money that is controlled by the
DNC yeah and they are not gonna let Pete
go they are not gonna he doesn't have
National electability they are not gonna
Michelle doesn't want to come a logo and
Gavin's the guy that's a key point
because don't forget to burn Joe Biden
exactly
don't forget what the DNC did to Bernie
yeah they wrecked him twice they didn't
want that social
loser
you know I you know what I'm
it's good for headlines it's good for
Ratings it's good to sell ads on CNN but
there is a certain reality that's under
this that we have there will be a
presidential election on a combination
of four and only four names Trump
DeSantis Biden and Newsom yep I agree
put the biz doc on a short clip rerun it
once a month I don't think I'm wrong
I'll say one thing and this actually
doesn't even have to do with Trump I
mean it's reference to him but I think I
what you said could not be understated
here okay or overstated about
Reinventing yourself and I'm going to
speak from personal experience and this
is why it's so important to have
somebody you trust and that has been
there before in your ear so Pat told me
for a couple years Adam you got to kind
of reinvent yourself you do the money
stuff save that money save the money
what else can you do what else are you
really really good at and we sat down we
had a strategy session well you're good
at networking you're good at
relationships you're good at partying
you know a lot of people like why don't
you kind of incorporate that that into
your brand and what was my first
reaction you didn't want to do it ah Pat
let me just save that money let me just
kind of do my thing and finally before
we move into the new office we had a
strategy session and I had to reinvent
myself and it's very hard to do to
reinvent yourself to do a self audit to
say all right this was my brand can I
switch what can I improve and this is
for everyone out there yeah this isn't
even a trump thing this is who's talking
to you who's in your ear who do you
trust who's your Mentor who's your
friend who's a leader that can kind of
help you through this process a but B
you have to look in the mirror and see
what can you do what can you do
different what can you improve upon so
that's something that I had to do that's
something that you've done that's
something that we've all done my fear
with Trump is you know they say a
leopard cannot change its spots he's
been doing this bit for 76 years it's
gonna be very hard for him to change if
he does if he does I think he can win if
he does the same old thing that you know
lock her up and build the wall and you
know victim mentality I think I think it
could have a very ugly ending for just
been a couple days we're going to find
out and see if this team can stay
healthy when I say team is the maga maga
next story next story all right and
horrific move Iran's Parliament vote
votes to execute
15 000 protesters let me say that one
more time folks execute as in Kill
fifteen thousand protesters to teach
hard lesson Iranian lawmakers in recent
days call for strict punishment for the
protesters who have been arrested on
Monday CNN reported that a letter signed
by 227 members of Iranian Parliament
this is not 20. this is not 40. this is
227 Iranian Parliament urged that the
protesters be given harsh punishment
that would serve as a good lesson in the
shortest possible time on Tuesday
Parliament did just that voting to
impose the death penalty
on all protesters in custody as a hard
lesson for all Rebels the majority in
favor of the penalty was considerable
227 folks out of 290 total members
matching the number of lawmakers who
signed the letter a court in Iran has
issued the first death sentence to a
person arrested for taking part of the
protests that have engulfed the
country's State media state state media
says keep this in mind it's 220 out of
290 okay this this is this is not
minority that's saying this we're like
oh my God they're so extremists no no
this is Iran's Parliament extremists 227
victory over 63 to have 15 000
protesters be executed so here's my my
concern that's my concern
um
human rights typically will be something
where you know Jimmy Carter's always
been known as the human rights person oh
he ran on human rights hey I'm a human
rights activist I'm a human rights
activist this is why I'm for zelinski
this is why I'm for zelinski zelinski is
the same person that came out and
tweeted out in no time after the Poland
story came out and I don't know if you
guys saw this uh how opportunistic he
started to lose more and more
credibility by the way of course as he's
doing this he put it us and had a call
with President Expo Express condolences
president of Poland exposed condolences
over the death of Polish citizens from
Russian missile Terror we exchange
available information or clarifying all
the facts all of Europe and world must
be fully protected from terrorist Russia
so let me get this straight had a call
with President of Poland Express
condolences over the death of Polish
citizens from Russian missile Terror so
he's already saying accused accused then
he says we exchange available
information and are clarifying all the
facts wait a minute that's in and what
do you call that an oxymoron like that's
like a complete opposite of
contradictory so you're saying this and
then Biden comes out hey we need another
37 billion dollars in Ukraine and then
Iran just announced that they want to
execute 15 000 people what is U.S going
to do about that if you're so concerned
about human rights this is an execution
this is not a bomb this is not dying
because of War this is not soldiers done
because they're on front lines this is
protesters and during covet if we had to
choose between the left and the right
that protests did the left was way more
about protests and riots than to write
the only time that right was protesting
is the January 6th which turned into an
Insurrection they categorize it but all
the other protesting and the rights that
happen the streets with business owners
nah it's just protesting is a part of
life in America no problem these are
peaceful protesters and now the
government saying 15 000 people are
going to get executed that's a
government
a massacre they're gonna I'd like to
know if in modern times anyone's ever
announced something like this from a
country that we have business dealings
with that we're thinking about giving
150 billion dollars to to have a nuclear
deal and saying wow let's say listen
they're they're okay people in the
government but they're going to execute
15 000 protesters okay here's my
question Pat and you nailed it where the
hell is where is all the countries where
where are we to help these people
Ukraine like by the way that was to me a
setup BS thing where they just they just
saw one Missile hit two people died God
Rest their souls but they took that
opportunity to go up and then the next
day we're about to send them 40 more
billion dollars I don't think people
grasp like think about this these people
are locked up right now probably getting
tortured 15 000 people that were just in
the street saying hey the government you
know you know we're oppressed or
whatever they're going to kill them hang
them or shoot them I don't know how it's
gonna happen where the hell is everybody
where are all these people I don't I
don't give a [ __ ] and I'm tired of
hearing well Kim Kardashian tweeted the
girl that was here that day Pat remember
she with the notes whatever she's like
well Kim tweeted I don't give a [ __ ]
about a tweet where the hell is the
force where's the military action where
is the people going in there going bro
that has to be stopped are we are we
gonna just let that happen 15
000 and a couple more you're not gonna
be younger people too Pat there's kids
that were protesting they're all gonna
get murdered dude and who are we
nobody's gonna what's the Tweet gonna do
not a goddamn thing this needs to be a
global repudiation of this this is this
is disgusting I mean we're talking about
protests I mean you went on a rant here
about what we're able to do here in
America that that went pretty viral but
this is just a message as like as as bad
as you may think you have it yeah as bad
as you may think you have it living in
the in the first world Western democracy
as victim mentality as you would like
these people just wanted to protest
basic freedoms not wearing a hijab and
they're facing the death penalty not
even facing they're getting it
overwhelmingly the the parliamentary
system in Iran voted for this what I'd
be interested in knowing that there's
probably no polling for this what is the
public sentiment like as the public you
know in in favor of this in Iran or they
all disgusted but they don't want to
raise their voices for fear of being
killed I think this is I think this is
what happens in a totalient totalitarian
theocracy where you know God wanted this
God wants these people dead for going
against the system and the government
it's just so disgusting it's crazy that
you say that just this morning because
on Instagram or just on that same post
people are like what are you talking
about America there's no way I go name
one thing that I said that isn't true
you could do whatever the hell you want
whatever you want these poor people just
stood in the goddamn Street and bro
they're sitting in there right now and
now they know their fate and nobody's
gonna do [ __ ] words to you nobody's
gonna do [ __ ] because there's no money
involved the worst thing that happens
here in America is they take away your
Twitter account okay yeah I'm sorry
you've got three YouTubers yeah Facebook
jails go to a protest here in Iran you
lose your life this is the beauty of
America like I'm reading the story and
like part of me is like this gotta be a
goddamn onion head like that this has to
be an absurd joke no this is the reality
of living in Iran yeah and this is the
reason that our leader our CEO pbd was
forced to escape his home country thank
God you know born in Iran made in
America but just a mat you know Pat one
of the things that you the reason you do
valuetainment is so you have a voice
right I mean you would not have a voice
in Iran you wouldn't be able to speak
what's on your mind you won't be able to
start a media company the the number one
thing that I think that you the reason
you do this we've all we've alluded to
this you could retire and sit on your
money and just be chilling at this point
but you do this because you have a voice
in your necessary voice and people need
to hear what you have to say because you
come from a country like this right you
know you know what's crazy with this so
let's let's actually play this out let's
play it out
so let's play it out that they do
what they just voted for
and they execute 15 000 people let's
let's play that out God forbid that
happens
what do the Iranian people do does that
make
the revolution a hundred times stronger
or does that get people to say oh I
don't say anything because something's
gonna happen what do you think happens
if they execute fifteen thousand I have
my own opinion what do you think happens
I think Pat because of the fear of
because mind you like I said this isn't
20 this isn't 40 this isn't 50 people 15
000 people are going to get executed I
think it's gonna it's gonna call it well
I hope what I hope people more people
going this year like in Brazil you see
they're yo in Brazil there's three
million people in the street yesterday
protesting because of the the rigged
election there I think it's gonna make
them not they're gonna they're gonna
calm down
what do you think I think I disagree I
think what happens is you usually
trigger this Noble reaction that says
I'm not giving up and now I know and I
thought I had nothing to lose now I know
I have nothing to lose because I'm not
going to live 85 years and look up one
day and say why didn't I do something
they just that's 15 000 just died for me
I am not giving up you attend to
Galvanize what's gone on take a look and
by the way this is just because we see
things this is such a dramatic statement
by a government and pbd you were asking
I haven't seen dramatic statements like
this but take a look at Darfur right
what's been going on in Darfur more than
15 000 people have died in Darfur and
you take a look at what's going on in
Syria I think over the last 10 years
more than 15 000 people died in Syria
but it hasn't been this dramatic
headline that says you 15 000 that are
in my cages right now I am done with you
and I'm doing it right now
um the West tends to watch things I mean
this goes back to the Tutsi and the Hutu
if you know you're if you know your
African history and how groups have
exterminated each other
on political or racial lines and I've
just never seen a government in the
modern time say the 15 000 that I have
in prison they're done right now you've
seen Syria you've seen Darfur that over
time rebels over here they 100 of them
die 150 of them die the numbers add up
I've just never seen it like this and I
think what that's about to happen if
they move on this they're going to
Galvanize this revolution we got two
minutes left I'll say I'll say one thing
30 seconds what do you think
Thanksgiving is um is coming up and you
know ever we're all going to be sitting
at the dinner table having conversations
with our family and then we joke oh
don't talk politics at the dinner table
to answer your question I want to know
what those dinner table conversations
are going to be for these 15 000
people's families having this
conversation and then their friends and
family saying did you hear about so and
so obviously you know about so-and-so
and what happens at this dinner table
will reflect upon what happens in the
country if there's people saying this is
unacceptable and there's fighting and
there's crying but if there are people
saying hey you know we can't do this I
don't think there'll be those types of
conversations but there'll always be
government support and you know in any
uh theocracy like this but those dinner
table conversations are going to be very
telling of what's going to happen moving
forward those 15 000 people how many
people think they're connected that's
all I'm just gonna say that million plus
people so how many people love those 15
000 people right what do you want to do
10 times 50 you want to do 50 times your
sister's cousins mothers everything
let's say a million people are tied to
those at least let's just say right if a
million are tight uh if if I all of a
sudden think my life is no longer worth
it and at any point this can happen to
me you're going to see a different side
of you there's something weird happens
when your life is like like this you can
lose it you you
fight in a different way you your spirit
enlar you know your spirit completely
changes when at any point this can
happen too so I don't know I I uh I I I
God forbid this happens I I pray for
this not to happen because this is a
tragic event but if Iran follows through
with this
I think it's going to be Mayhem uh to
what's going to happen to them people
that are going to show up from places
they've never ever seen before people
who were not involved are going to get
involved at levels they never seen
before it is not going to be a pretty
thing for them to do people like this
don't make it it's going to be
catastrophic for Iran's government if
they even think about doing this year
it's not going to be pretty anyways uh
we're at the end of it uh gang if you
enjoyed today's podcast give us a sub at
500 000 we're going to do a live podcast
together and celebrate the Milestone of
collectively without you this podcast
wouldn't happen I have a whole Channel
called valentayman with three and a half
four million subscribers and a bunch of
other channels we made this because we
wanted to talk about current events and
be a little bit more free to talk about
the topics that we want and somehow
someone whether you were a validator or
not you're here with us we appreciate
you thank you uh being with us it we
enjoy just as much as you're enjoying it
for those that do whether we agree or
disagree I enjoyed period and reminder
again next week not next week what's the
day after Thanksgiving is next
Thanksgiving next week or the following
week a week from next week really next
week tomorrow okay Friday next Friday we
are launching the gold signature series
of merch with valuetainment gold and
we're going to have the first ever
numbered hats that's coming out that's
gold and navy blue with future looks
bright on the side there's only 200 of
those hats numbered if you want to be
the first to get this link to buy this
merch because it will sell out and I'm
gonna call the first 50 orders we're
gonna FaceTime and have a call together
when we place the order and you buy the
whole bundle text award merch m-e-r-ch
Tyler put that in the comment in the
chat in the description text the word
merch merch to
310-340-1132 once again
310-340-1132 to be the first to get the
details on the merch tomorrow we got
podcasts we got a lot of other stuff
coming on I think tomorrow is a micro if
I'm not mistaken is it tomorrow or next
week tomorrow the final week on November
22nd I'm bringing three different people
who have all written a book on what
happened to John F Kennedy and we're
going to debate what happened to John F
Kennedy assassination you don't want to
miss that podcast and we got a lot of
other surprises coming soon have a great
one everybody take care bye-bye